wade leblanc still trying to pick up
that first win six starts really jimmy
the bottom line he's done his job to
keep you in games and for the most part
he has done that freddie freeman 290 24
home runs and he is driven in 60.
into center bader is there and he makes
the catch three fly ball outs and a one
two three for wade leblanc portugue this
is his second career start versus st
louis and his fourth overall appearance
coming in 1-0 with a 279 era in his
career versus the cardinals and here is
arenado a three-run homer last night
gave st louis an early lead tukey works
quickly two balls in a strike
and the breaking ball popped up into
shallow left who's got it it's going to
be duvall three fly-outs for each
starter after a scoreless winning in st
louis
back to back walks and freddie freeman
hits with two on and one out
freddie jumps on the first one and hits
it to right field of base hit carlson
will not have a play at the plate it's
cut off freddie freeman ambushes leblanc
and the braves strike first it's one to
nothing
61st rbi for freddie freeman people
watching at home it's not this easy how
freddy makes it look it just gets a
pitch and
flicks the wrist for an rbi single but
he's so good at it we always talk about
a chip one of the best first pitch
hitters in baseball if it's over the
plate he's going to go that ball's a
little bit on the outer part but doesn't
great breed by ozzie he went right off
the bat and gets the braves on the board
that is freddie freeman's 36th career
hit in the cardinals home park kisner
hitting just 192. he did fill in quite
nicely for yadier molina when he was out
for a bit
deep left there it goes home run is
first of the year
[Applause]
you don't just call them all the time
you can see the match-up right there
with the fastball with the velocity
with the lack of movement
and i just thought this might be a good
matchup for kids right here
and he got a pitch
been 45 games since his last home run
september 1st of 2019.
oh he knew it
that's a great replay right there
that's he's got walk-off replays right
there look at this oh god him it's a
good feeling my friend and he has tied
the game three balls two strikes one out
arenado at the plate two runners aboard
1-1 is our score we're in the third
toussaint delivers to arenado swinging a
fly ball left field backing up as a left
letter over his head
one run scores and going into second
base is arenado and he's called out at
the second base bag on a terrific throw
by duvall
to albie's cardinals might want to look
at that
but it is a rbi nonetheless for arenado
who drove in carlson and the cardinals
have a 2-1 lead
running from first to third and the ball
goes to second base you can keep on
trucking
it's a good hustle right here by
everyone and just
nice play by the left fielder hit it too
hard great play by duvall it's close and
they did get him it's his 30th hit with
runners in scoring position this year
the cardinals grabbed their first lead
of the night to make it a 2-1 ball game
here in the third one away in the
atlanta fourth jack peterson two quick
strikes
swing and a fly ball hit toward the gap
in right center field that ball is gone
jack peterson with a line drive home run
ties the game at two that hit off the
top of the wall and bounced off into the
seats
and fire in the hole
for jack peterson
a bomb over the right field wall a 2-2
contest
gretchen caney did a perfect time to do
the g g and nick greene set it up with
the lefties but here's another one just
gets the ball up in the zone
and lines this thing out eight for 20
versus left-handers now hitting 400 just
continues to do great work for atlanta
one-on-one out the new picture is jesse
chavez and what has he done so many
times this season restore order that's
what the braves are looking for right
here nothing in two de young with two
outs and runners in scoring position
one-two pitch
gets away here comes o'neill he will
score and the cardinals get the break
they needed they laid it three to two
chavez had not allowed any of his four
inherited runners to score this year but
that is in and out of the glove of smith
this is and it's 3-2 this is a cross-up
right here i think he shakes a couple of
times here
fastball change-up
in the breaking ball but i don't know
what he throws here though something
hard
that is definitely not a two
no sure
we go to the seventh at busch stadium
cards lead it three
to two five straight scoreless outings
for the cardinal left-handed reliever
but he has walked four hitters and he
almost hit peterson
and he did hit peterson that grazed him
on the way by and cabrera a guy that
throws a hundred miles an hour and often
has no idea where it's going
that's a big advantage
i think they're gonna check this one i
thought it might have grazed them there
i guess like anything seventh inning you
might as well take a yeah well review
takes place in new york
and you can see the ball
graze and change directions that's ever
so small
key you see it just barely change and so
the call to the plate by marvin hudson
correct he was grazed with that pitch
and the braves have the tying run aboard
and that'll bring kevin smith up to the
plate
throw down his second and they run into
and out and a nice pick by paul young
good play by andrew pisner too wow both
of both ends of this you got a guy
trying to deflect 100 mile an hour
fastball nice job andrew really nice
hands here by the young gets the short
hop the tag and the out and a big out
nobody on pretty simple just fastball
away 3-2 pitch
inside corner
struck him out dennis says cabrera gets
the strikeout bottom of the seventh
inning with the cardinals clinging to a
one-run lead goldschmidt at the plate
2-1 is ripped out to left-center tommy
edmond will score
base hit for goldie
and makes it a 4-2 st louis lee just see
it with the at-bats he was taking
tonight two bodies in better position
he's kind of feel like he's getting
locked back in and the cardinals now
lead four to two paul goldschmidt
delivers they play with fire here with
austin reilly he's reached in 17
straight games
and riley hammers it down the line
hanging slider and we are tied yeah
lawson riley comes through again chip
gets a hanging slider absolutely hammers
it to left field
four hitters now for the braves in this
inning even though he got two outs all
four guys have been all over every pitch
gallegos
comes in last night in a 4-4 game gives
up three and now austin riley ties it
with a two run bomb
just inside the foul pole the on base
streak continues 18 games in a row eight
homers 20 rbis in that stretch the bases
are loaded now he's got to throw a
strike
he lost him a bases loaded walk in the
braves lead and all three runs belong to
gallegos and atlanta has taken the lead
five to four you talk about tiny strike
zones votes got one right here
and another walk this is incredible
he's thrown 20 pitches
he's throwing four strikes
three balls two strikes two down bases
loaded
here it is dazzy
ball four low and away and the braves
will see another run walk in
four straight walks an rbi for ozzie it
has turned into a five run eighth the
braves have high five to the cardinals
and it's seven to four and here comes
mike shelton justin miller is on
and he will face jorge soler i've never
seen what we have seen in this eighth
inning before and here it is
he missed it
another walk
that's five consecutive walks and heck
jeff they may set the record tonight
that's what five consecutive auction
four
with the bases loaded 26 is now too shy
of the all-time right game was four to
four and the braves didn't even have to
swing the bat and here is freddie
freeman to put the cherry on top maybe
the big ending for the braves and he
will though it's into the glove of sosa
nice play
and mundo shows up
on the outfield grass beginning for
atlanta bringing will smith in this
situation take no chances and will's
done good work as of late on one pitch
is popped up
foul ground freddie is there how sweet
it is the braves are over 500. brian
schnitker yeah wow indeed two great
comeback wins for atlanta in as many
nights as atlanta sweeps the cardinals
in saint louis for the first time in
three years
[Applause]